how you doing I'm Kevin Hart Dwayne
Johnson here I'm Margot Robbie and I'm
Chris Messina I'm ASA I'm Emma
I'm GT and this is animal times for lad
Bible the time takes this cat to give up
name three swear all those you porn porn
Eskimo to in the time it takes this
horse to escape named five websites
BuzzFeed life Idol Google she's kicking
man should we start this game over I'm
brain dead it's why we take this cat to
make a leap of faith name three famous
English people
[Applause]
you have let yourself in the time it
takes this dog to steal a sausage name
five things beginning with P well
potatoes pants Paris paparazzi and four
types of takeaway Chinese Indian pizza
what hey I love a great falafel
tabbouleh salad it's all above board the
time it takes this Pope to wake up
name three superheroes I am spider-man
in the time it takes his dog to escape
named for male singers
Ginuwine ed sheeran thanks not sure
bobby williams
me the dog is so hypnotic my mama shoes
on your shoes Oh Phil Collins okay it
was your first I don't know what is that
I'm having a strike or is that what is
that let's place happen
all right in the time it takes this dog
to a sin to the ceiling named for things
beginning with T tags
tank tick [ __ ] says I don't know man
my payments man I felt like the doll was
gonna die I got real nervous the time it
takes this dog to pop his balloon aim
for coffee James Luck's Pete's coffee
Starbucks and and I couldn't hold it
yeah I said that simp stirs I just made
it up
Sam stirs it's incredible things we find
in a bedroom in the time it takes this
dog to squeeze through the wall name
five parts of the human body and you
have the toad you got the thumb you got
to know the scalp and the chin okay
check this one out in the time it takes
this bearded dragon Loretta to pick up
the worm then for sauces sauce ketchup
mayonnaise is a girl you don't barbecue
for this class he's gone student so in
the time it takes this dog to break the
spaghetti twice name three total dog
Asian countries Japan Japan Japan Japan
and John
and the time it takes this dog to kill
Apple this is dog no name for because
I'm lovely - glass onion take a pony
octopus garden the time it takes his dog
to abandon it stick name for things you
found that cargo telephone phone charger
that was tough hey no I wouldn't got
that by the way very smart dog he said
just stick just went on about his day
and the time it takes his dog to class
named for famous American singers
Beyonce jay-z Billy Joel Elton John no
oh Jesus Christ you guys are having out
in the time it takes this dog to fall
off the edge name three modes of
transport without wheels
one was that miss transport was that
means for every doesn't it
[Music]
in the time it takes this dog to climb
one step name for social media websites
Twitter Instagram Facebook I mean the
time it takes for this time to make a
splash named five famous British people
go for Jeremy's did you know an attorney
takes his dog to climb one step name
four frames each find in the bedroom Lou
nipple clamps handcuffs good good Oh
pillows in the time it takes this iguana
to pick up the worm name three British
people go Queen I'll be blunt and the
time it takes his dog to ascend to the
ceiling named for K cities London London
York
the dogs going off Jesus Christ
anytime you take this cup to give up
just to give aa name 5-wood runs its
show snow snow snow blow oh yeah in the
time it takes this dog to ascend to the
Sailor or romantic comedies oh they are
not the ones who answer this question I
was too distracted by the point he's hit
the seal a side in the time it takes the
song to send the sealing name four types
of cocktail mai tai sex on the beach
nato the time it takes this cat to make
a leap of faith name three famous
english people running at concern Emma
Thompson oh no you work in an industry
with famous people what's happening to
me no honestly in eternity care to make
a leap of faith name five people tapping
sausage pepperoni meatball peppers
mushrooms
[Music]
thank you guys what a great game I think
you should call it how to know when
you're having a stroke you know I show
you funny this is the funny skit
[Laughter]
you